You were thinking
about it the whole time
it was happening before you?
The guy that was --
had the apartment,
the one that was yelling.
"Shut up!"
Yeah, that was --
Let me tell you something.
If the other guy said
that the yeller
was one of the big problems
why he couldn't
live with him,
I'd believe him.
I'd go, "Well,
he's proven himself today
to be a crazy person."
But that wasn't
his complaint.
He became the parent
for no reason.
He still owes him the money.
So, guess what?
Even if it was $300 a month,
then guess what?
Then he deserves
everything he wants.
[ Lighter clicks ]
If it's any amount of money,
he should get all the money.
And don't tell me
the place he lived at
wasn't at least
worth $300 a month.
So, where's that
[bleep] money?
So, give him all of the money.
The other guy's a [bleep]
rip-off artist, and he knows it.
And he might not
be a yeller,
but I bet today,
it brings the rage out in him
and he sees that guy
sitting there [bleep] yelling.
He has a temper problem,
but maybe he's [bleep] right,
that other guy.
Who gives a [bleep]
Guess what, we still pay
the [bleep] rent.
What do you think?
We were worried that
your energy would sag...
[ Laughter ]
...after three --
three cases,
but you can really handle --
you can handle
a big docket.